right now Oh your mic I could totally
see your say but right now Molly is
passive they only do things that they're
told to do hey I'm Mike Tyson and we're
at hotboxing today and mean Evan has
well well my it's been probably around
for a few decades but the technically
yeah they've been working on since the
1950s
it's just that technology is finally God
what they trying to get rid of people or
something no no no people up to do more
important work right think about the
doctor doesn't have to treat like the
common cold if we could focus on working
like kind of cure for cancer all right
what do you think about the I'm very
skeptical of AI men but I understand it
you know I understand well actually I
don't understand it so how did you get
here why are we talking to you today
totally by accident of it of course now
where are you from where I'm originally
from New York yeah yeah how'd you get
involved well in in AI I was working
working at IBM in the manager consulting
arm and developed a set of patents and
talking about could machines learn
because you certain things and there was
a research project going on called
Watson that could you build a machine
that could play jeopardy right so could
understand what people are trying to say
and interact and act if it's human think
like it's human and as a result of some
of the things that I've done I got
involved very early early into the
project and you know we had the Jeopardy
challenge all these things and I was one
of the people that was advocating to
build what we call a Watson ecosystem
where let's let anybody use technology
let them bring their expertise
and solve problems so they can build
products and services like in sports
media agriculture education and so forth
and we just be the engine that helps to
actually do that well I think you
mention agriculture how would how would
it be a necessity for agriculture yeah
well I think there's there's
opportunities to do more with less so
like in in Africa there's an initiative
called Project Lucy where you have a lot
of people that they don't have access to
a lot of water or maybe sunlight good
weather might suffer from you know pests
and that kind of stuff they're using AI
to help figure out what crops to plant
where to plant them how to do things
with less water so they could actually
grow more food with less resources how's
that working out though yes they I do
that so it's a combination of looking at
like weather data
topsoil information since information
about insects and how much water is
available kind of plants how much water
they might need like to grow an element
takes 10 gallons of water so maybe
that's not the best crop totally given
with information not doing the workforce
well not not yet I know that people are
working on robots to do some of these
things I know that some of the vineyards
the wineries are now using robotic grape
pickers so someone work is trying to get
done the Y is like is essentially to
make our lives easier is that right
I I wouldn't say necessarily easier I
think it's to free us up to do more
complicated or complex work be more
creative
it's the showa stuff it's gonna show hey
you should do this this is what should
be done in some cases yeah it couldn't
help us is like like a digital assistant
but think about all the low-level grunt
work we tend to do if a I could actually
do that for us would that free us up to
do more important work so thick thick
think about all the research someone
like even having listened our
individuals in general is supposed to
have this artificial intelligence
two individual could buy this in some
cases yeah it depends on probably more
like you have a painfull assistant or a
slave or something right sort of yeah
wow that's pretty interesting what do
you think about who who can afford the
only that the rich people will be able
for that when you make a low budget
people for people of middle class so a
lot of people are actually trying to do
that and some things like Alexa and
Syria are available to everybody but
there's an initiative called loving AI
where they're trying to use AI to be an
emotional support tool for abused people
especially abused women interested life
would be totally different than how
would you do that supposed crime would
be different yes
crime would be different there either be
no crime out they have the intelligent
life doing the crime for my expressing
the crime day how can be done in a
perfect perfection right absolutely
have you seen The Terminator I have I've
seen all the movies yeah I mean do you
ever get concerned that we're heading
towards this Skynet future
personally I don't I know a lot of
people had that concern but we're not
moving towards like a self-aware machine
we're moving towards human machine
integration that would be going towards
becoming like cyborgs but if they're
thinking on why can't they think hey
guys these guys are inferior why we
thinking right so right now all the AI
systems but I would think for me that we
should be giving them orders
well right right now right now oh you're
Mike I could totally see what you're
saying but right now all AI is passive
they only do things that they're told to
do
matrix and it scares me because it looks
like we're headed that way you know
people are so dependent on their
machines and their devices it's like
dude are we [ __ ] just running
ourselves into that little sack getting
just pumped for our juices to feed the
machines it's it's a real fear it's a
real concern I think that's the societal
question you know I'm not no scholarly
guy but that the first thing I would
think these guys were idiots right yeah
well that that's that's also human
nature to think that what you have about
fear yet have that fear because that's
what's happened throughout like history
that as we evolved we replaced the like
you know the previous generation version
of ourselves right I just finished this
book sapiens Mike lease where he talks
about basically how homo safe
I believe they have different ones the
creature for sure we're in amalgamation
of different homo species but homo
sapiens are the deadliest creature to
walk planet Earth ever think we've
destroyed more rationally thank well
it's crazy
we're clever that's for sure it's a
quote from the Bible a perspective base
started since the beginning of time no
doubt I never knew that but you should
always been the only one ahead
fear-based my life no we all got it we
all have we all have fears which is
either it could be a driver a motivator
or we cower in front of it and freak out
right so you've you've done a few really
interesting things that we're gonna talk
about okay first I want to talk to talk
to you about Facebook having to shut
down their AI because this thing created
a language of its own and started doing
that nobody knew what it was doing and
that's what they were fainting thing why
we have to listen to the [ __ ] we
could do this faster so tell us about
that explain that we we get we're at a
time where people are doing things they
may not fully understand anymore whether
they're building and machines learn and
think differently than we do like if you
see a picture of a truck we look and see
the truck the AI might believe the
pixels the different things and trying
to figure out what what is that that's
not looking for a necessary like a car
or a shape but something else and
because they think differently what
happened like with the Facebook guys is
the the to a ice trophy tonight there's
a better language there's a more
efficient language to use and say when
up creating their own language and
suddenly they're talking so fast as a
computer thing making this language it
scares me scares me I look I totally get
that right and it's natural for us to be
afraid especially we don't fully
understand that's one of the reason why
I wrote a book recently to try and talk
to those fears those concerns what that
feeling that feeling so today there's
really called artificial empathy where
they can understand or recognize a
understand they can recognize emotion
but they don't really understand or feel
it themselves so they can tell if you're
happy or sad so how can I can lie to it
you could try if it knows body language
you can tell if you're lying that's
intense
I've heard of apps that you can
communicate with an AI basically a
counselor or a therapist you can text
your feelings into it it's like oh
that's all right you know today's a
tough day everybody has two hard days
but I I don't know man talking to a
robot
there's don't you feel like we're losing
a lot of personal connection we lose in
that way
our phones yeah - each other no longer
talking to each other technically yeah
[Laughter]
conceivably individuals could create
their own ai's to start answering their
texts for them they could some people
have actually done that
have you seen google duplex I haven't so
Google's created a little ai where you
can just order to do something and it'll
go make reservations at a restaurant for
you it'll make a doctor's appointment so
if time goes on and we reach the 2020s
and 30 we're becoming more
disenfranchised with one another because
of the computers in the high tech stuff
we're becoming more sociable I see here
Google duplex AI assistant calls local
businesses to make appointments and it
sounds like it's a person so yeah it's
crazy so you guys actually created a
meteorologist in China suppose I say
this to some I'll get paid next week can
I still buy this no way this is watch
this but this is this meteorologist that
is [ __ ] artificial intelligence it's
not a real dude but can you tell by if
you didn't tell you that
not really do they understand passion
understand it yeah I mean it looks damn
it's as a video it's a real guy as far
as I could tell we've got a major
problem with homelessness and people
can't get jobs and this takes away more
jobs doesn't it some some jobs will be
lost some will be hated do you think be
found what efficient attorneys could
inspire you homeless people they could
there's actually a couple of nom
it's trying to help homeless people
using AI tools but at the other day.i is
really about training so if you could
teach the machine something that'll be
able to do it that's basically how it
works so the thing is do you have a way
to teach the machine if you do you tell
me unfused to intelligence to run to
handle can I pretty much hold a church
why everybody else is doing it could be
yeah robot robot priests there's a lot
of cyber criminals out there that are
really trying to figure out what they
can do for a bad yeah
all right and there's agencies out there
to try to figure out what they can do
for good it's a dinner day all this it's
just a tool all right interesting
hopefully creating innovating you know I
actually believe that things like AI
might help us be more human actually
give us more time to interact with each
other and experience emotional
intelligence a lot of people are
thinking the process of this thing
becoming mature yeah people we gotta
figure out a way to do how are we gonna
get people here's a problem I have
they've done studies with monkeys where
they take in a child monkey away from
its mother and they've put it in Sal
whatever a room whatever it might be
with a fake mother a pseudo mother like
a big puppet mother monkey they're
comparing that to studies of the baby
monkey with the real mother and that
what they found a hundred percent of the
time is that the monkey raised by the
fake mother would grow up to have
emotional issues dysfunction and its
personality would be more tended towards
violence and what they believe it was is
what it was this
lack of something organic some organic
love that that monkey was not receiving
so while a I might be able to give us
all those answers would we still get
that comfort that we get from you know
us being in this room together and
talking yeah tell me that honestly I
don't know I mean we can have an AI
convey those those messages but those
words but is it gonna resonate I don't
know
you look at what's going on just with
social media and stuff and the ability
to reach out and hear company worries
I'm emotion if I mean how do they know
when they respond the burp the monkey or
anything
I really feel there's some human
connection just from physical presence
and engagement that is somehow lost
through all this yeah right one of the
biggest challenges in the United States
is I think they said we're 40 percent of
people suffer from loneliness yes which
you think is amazing given that you can
stay touch via Facebook Instagram all
these things yes but I think because
we're doing so much more of that we lack
that human interaction yeah and I think
that's a driver why we can never really
substitute that but the hope is in your
eyes is that the evolution of AI will
lead to us having more time for that
that's yeah that's my hope yeah article
about it do you think that humans have
this innate urge to create more and
build more and never be satisfied with
what we've done I I do I feel like
there's something that drives god
complex yeah you know we have gone
complexes either we want to be gotta we
want to be um what's the word want to be
applauded by God hmm you know I mean
when got to acknowledge us in a weird
way he acknowledged its boss
accumulating a lot of stuff and giving
it within his name that's the first
thing I think people ever did was
worship you know as before even knowing
about religion
we always worship that's how my society
has the worship society we see somebody
that we
- we actually worship them you know
complex yeah they inspire us you know
man how will you see a guy this guy
makes you want to become this you didn't
even do anything till you didn't touch
it yes see this guy then you start
watching him on top of it he said this
is what I want to do and this happens
you know that must happen since the
beginning of time Mike I mean are you
gonna become a professor you should
teach a class at UCLA no we start thing
about artificial intelligence you start
thinking about that how is this gonna
happen that's kind of scary stuff what
we're good are we gonna be if we have
all efficient something what is the
purpose is gonna be really to
communicate with each other that's what
we're trying to figure out Mike right by
that time this stuff keeps this stuff
makes us happy keeping away from each
other we could communicate with people
at a distance well technology has been
around for forever people thought
tractors would put farmers out of work I
mean it's just that change is happening
faster and faster but I like the way
you're thinking you should teach a class
at UCLA I'm like maybe God ban a machine
god man in machine Mike Tyson do you
ever feel like this is all just another
piece of the the uber wealthy white
man's game to just enslave humanity no
no not at all no there's there's so many
people trying to use things like a and
their technology for good yeah I mean
there's a whole UN initiative AI for
good you have tens of thousands of
volunteers yeah yeah for good what good
am i you know human being what was the
Micra for good we're always gonna be
people for good but I think again it's a
tool it's a it's a tool to help us do
well alright I got it became for people
to start getting along with one another
we just really probably even if it's 200
years five we get started getting along
with each other it's crazy you know me
if suppose we see just war I don't even
know he just hope he sees again I'm
Callum
really a new um it's a new century where
we have started getting along with one
another communicating with one another
truth more distance with the
intelligence it's just true I think
that's why we have to figure how we keep
the human interaction up it's it's easy
to rail hate against someone you never
see but if you try saying it face to
face it's a different story yeah yeah
they have Skinner would that be
mechanical stuff yeah I mean we could
talk about that debate there are people
working on sex robots relations between
men and women did it it won't be a very
told yeah it'll be like the movie her no
I haven't seen that great movie
yeah I've been I'm really tempted I want
to watch it but name name a football
play that you would you have to face
against Mario Williams alright so put a
put a guy that I would know in that
position Lawrence Taylor alright good so
can you arrange for him or fish the
intelligence of course can order fish
the tongue is arranged for him to be at
the same age as Lawrence Taylor yeah you
play together yeah so Mike doesn't like
this but the Internet is screaming for a
Mike Tyson versus Muhammad Ali matchup
yeah
could you use AI to distill down all the
data and all the information points of
these two guys styles of fighting
throughout their careers to have like a
legit round
oh yeah oh yeah good where would you get
the data from would you get it from
information written in sports magazines
but you get the data you'll actually
have the AI will actually rights yeah
and they get the data from that getting
a little punchy how would he know how
would they know um if the punch is
thrown with bad intentions or not you'd
have to train the ants and that stuff
but just like just by looking at they
can tell like the speed of the punch and
a bunch of other information off of it I
can't believe the speed and the power
even by even the training even the trash
talk well how can how would they know if
that punch in them is gonna hurt him and
not come out and kill them or how would
they know that but they would have to
take a look and see like what's the
power of the punch and then what's the
other guy's ability to either block or
absorb just based on it so it's it's
like trillions of calculations going on
in a fraction and second to figure all
these things out you could run the fight
multiple times and actually that's why
they revolt - yeah that's why they I
[ __ ] revolts they're getting trillions
of data points a second yeah for the
record would like to see that fight if
it does happen so if we make that fight
say we make that fight on artificial
intelligence would I get paid for the
fight today for I would say I would say
so cuz I'm gonna need your likeness
information about you oh you on Musk's
neural link and what that technology is
all about my understanding is that it's
basically like augmented consciousness
where the individual hooks something up
I don't know what the [ __ ] a a chip in
your brain or whatever it might be an
implant and now you have access to an
internet like collective consciousness
to use a young intern it's called like
Excel reality it's almost extended
reality
yeah the Claude XR and so you ever
watched the movie Iron Man yeah yeah
yeah and you see you know Tony Stark
he's who's behind the machine machine
he's playing around with the stuff
that's that's an example of XR so that
you have you're interacting in the real
world and the virtual world at the same
time machine yeah is that real that too
much dark thing not yet yeah it will be
yeah you could get a computer in the
computer to say hey listen you weren't
disowned this would happen to you and
say listen suppose I want this round how
will my life turns out
this stuff actually exists to a certain
extent you can think about there's
infinite possibilities but AI could run
infinite combinations right would never
stop but you can figure a lot of things
up but it's all about probability right
some things are more likely than other
things so you could use AI to help you
make decisions yeah to influence your
mic don't go that way cuz that's gonna
[ __ ] you up go this way you don't want
to go to this party you want to go to
this Australian University using an AI
assistant right now to help other
students figure out what do I take what
what queer past it might be interested
in ever if you ever watch the show dark
mirror block black mirror sorry yeah
black mare yeah I was just about to ask
you if you watch this there's an episode
on there where people have a social
rating right and great everybody else
China China is actually doing that they
have something called a smiles program
are watching in 2020 we're using AI you
get people get rated on their behavior
right so now people hey how are you
doing nice shirt love the jacket type of
stuff what are they saying it because
they're genuine or they're trying to get
points and the government set up that if
your score is not high enough you can't
do certain things like you can't buy
plane tickets you can't ride this dude I
just watched this episode my [ __ ]
mind
what is crazy it's a crazy episode cuz
you can see how we could get there we
could be there and of course China's
they're doing it I don't know man
I think you mean great do you mean drive
some people in thing yeah yeah well I
think we're going and say we're totally
going to see my drive some people are
saying yeah I can see I can see being
insane it's almost like being in a room
by yourself
hopefully AI can bring it cuz we're not
stopping it's not like somebody's gonna
pull the [ __ ] emergency brake now
well who's gonna give up their phone
exactly not even me remember that
remember at one particular time you like
when we didn't have phones that we knew
all these numbers in our head yeah
I don't have one in my head now
no lose my formation are we going too
hard on you no fun so what what are you
working on now what's your latest
project I'm compromising the United
Nations and I'm trying to help them
fulfill the sustainable development
goals so I'm very much about AI for good
okay and so just trying to help them
figure out how we can do things like and
hunger and poverty try and help with
income inequality gender inequality
these types of things protect life
improve agriculture using technology
like AI so I for one feel that I'm
really lucky I know there are some
things that are not gonna be changed
some things can't be stopped like the
phones AI capable of hunting for
treasure not that I know of maybe maybe
we can create an AI pirate Mike it's
possible you know like well what do you
think man I never had put go to this
particular moment it's pretty scary it
can be scary or it could be an
opportunity right it's all about how we
use the doggy dog if he doesn't make it
if he's swimming and he drowns [ __ ] him
and it's all about me I I think it's
again how we teach the AI we tell them
like it's not about one person over
another it's about compassion right they
may not feel it if they understand that
something should work then that's what
they're gonna do but it's up to us to do
that training we have to figure out how
to eat properly trained in AI how do you
train a way to communicate with human
beings how do you know when a person's
like you said before how do they know
expressing compassion they could tell
from body language
we're choice tone of voice pitch of
voice so it's looking for non-verbal
clues that what's your emotions don't
know how to react to compassion only if
you teach it only if you teach it
neva wouldn't understand that level of
compassion that's when it just feels the
feeling of compassion reacts how they
would it would it would detect like if
you're sad that you're sad and would try
something and say 42% I mean I try and
cheer you up and maybe say no that would
be interesting one like it's a sad sad
song not sad enough hmm
would it smoke weed if you taught it
okay
how would it would it have well you'd
have to build the thing for it to exist
in that goes you have information that
wheel right yeah yeah you could use AI
to actually figure out like based on
your preference your mood what's the
right strain to use that would be cool
yeah let me down but then it might you
know not like it's it's deal man my
figure itself out and be like [ __ ] this
ah yeah I'm gonna prescribe the strain
that will [ __ ] this guy up right now it
could do that can it really only to
become self-aware and you treated that
because there's no way that computers
gonna check itself or what about how
2001 a Space Odyssey uh-huh
started off okay they were buddies he
looked out for him and then he's like
[ __ ] y'all look good happy one day
ya know what happens when the computers
have to differ
what happens then do we pull the plug
they fight each other they they might
what's that movie I Robot yeah right you
had one set of AI that decided was gonna
bottle up and enslave the humans yet
another AI that said no we have to help
him save the humans again it all boils
down to how we train the a
and it's a tool can't get around it you
can teach you to be good or you can
teach it to be bad Microsoft started a
tweet bot an AI Tweetbot and less than a
day people taught it to be racist
let's put it out there if they interact
with it's gonna learn and people taught
it to be racist as well I think we
enhance the racism to the next level
well if you teach the AI or building AI
to do that that's exactly what's going
to happen so I saw that happen because
there's people that erases and they're
gonna teach racist anything that
accepted and absorbs it and it's gonna
go out there and this way this is a
people problem right yeah how do you
deal with those people [ __ ] people
get rid of them you wanna get a machine
joint get rid of people would you leave
[Laughter]
I'll just tell you this you're in a
meeting so you took my let's check this
guy out
read him out is he good to do business
way you could you could do that China
they actually have those Google glass
the police use them so as people walk by
they can see who you are get your name
your address where you work we've been
the last two hours do you have your
rests or things like that already yeah
already where China
but suppose the guy never been arrested
though and stuff can it read a person
say this is a no-good [ __ ] Mike
while you do business bodies they have a
eye that could detect if people are
lying I'd be good could you imagine
trying to hack my business sometimes you
know but can you manage trying to pick
up a girl to us within she isn't here
they can read by language it's already
hard all these just became ten times
I'll probably thousand times oh yeah
[ __ ] way to go I think we in general
don't know we want we have to figure it
out you know that's true then we knows
we'll come along with this cuz whatever
we want to have luggage that comes with
it that we may not be efficient would
hang and I'll be good I mean up a good
so what's your perfect world scenario
with this stuff is it in everybody's
home does every is everyone linked up by
one single AI Rock sure enough that's my
perfect world scenario I think we're
moving that direction my will a I get to
know who we are know what I owe ya it's
it's already happened know what we want
and what comment you can make us a
better person the worst person which is
the right direction to go yeah that some
of that work is already happening we're
on that path my my ideal situation or
scenario ideal world I guess is we're
actually using this technology not just
to make money not just for entertainment
but we're trying to do social good with
it as well yeah jail time B would be so
much different if we had efficient uh if
we had robot judges that's something the
UN is very seriously looking at if you
had robot judges ooh interesting you'd
have less bias but probably less
compassion or leeway in the ruling so
more by the book I don't know good or
bad bad it'll it all depends write
slippery slope yeah I mean very
interesting them well is there anything
you want to talk about before that we
haven't
before we get out of here I just
mentioned that I know there's a lot of
gloom and doom out there and I'm very
much an optimist as you guys can tell
right I think there's this threat or
there's opportunity and I think we can
focus on the opportunity it's a tool
that's why I wrote my book because I
want to help empower now I appreciate
that man
I appreciate your optimism and it gives
me some hope - it's all about mindset
right yeah no doubt man no doubt and I
appreciate that if we plug in the
positive to the machines hopefully they
continue to perpetuate that yep
well thanks for coming in Mike you got
anything else brother yeah love to have
you back on love - yeah definitely
you'll be our tech guy all right come in
we'll talk about science and AI and
technology blew me away today it was
awesome man
thank you my pleasure I hope to see that
Muhammad Ali Mike Tyson fight one that's
gonna be interesting all right so well
until next time we're out of here
Coolio thanks guys thank you
[Music]